[Applause]
well yeah thank you very much for this
kind introduction
so exactly this talk is called pre
connect prefetch preload and pre wats
an introduction to the resource ins and
I would like to talk about why web
performance matters at all in the first
place so why are we are we even thinking
about improving website speeds then I
would like to explore explore why some
websites load slowly and then go into
resource hints and how you can use them
to make your website load much faster
than they might do currently so why
should we care about web performance at
all the simple answer is because it has
shown to have a significant significant
effect on on business results so large
companies ran a lot of studies that
showed exactly this so I want to show
two of them Amazon allegedly once run a
study where they deliberately slowed the
websites down by only 100 milliseconds
and they already saw a drop in sales by
1% which is obviously kind of
significant when you are operating on a
scale as Amazon does and the second one
is from another large us-based company
there's called Google and they found out
that 53% of users will abandon a website
if it takes longer than 3 seconds to
load I'm apparently a bit more patient
because I often wait a bit longer but
this is what they have found out but I
think it's even more about something
more important than business it's also
about empathy because especially with
those that have to endure who or network
conditions then then we have and I think
we ought not to take anybody's time as
granted and we should not be wasting it
if we can do can do better and I think
we as web developers are the ones that
are in the position and maybe even
responsible to deliver fast websites I
would like to now to go to why websites
load slowly and in order to do that we
need
- no at first or talk about what
actually is a website so usually a
website is a small text documents that
contains references to other small
documents such as scripts or images or
CSS files that also need to be
downloaded in order for the website to
be useful at all and this is kind of
different - for example if you download
one large binary file for example if you
download download a video and in order
to to download a website you actually
have to send data right and if you think
about it that data don't get it it
doesn't get beams and has to travel and
I would like to give an example where
I'm in Germany and I will request a
website in New York so and if I do this
then there's the distance is roughly six
thousand 100 kilometres from Hamburg to
New York and then also 6130 kilometres
back because I also need to get to get
an answer right so and how fast can data
travel so there's this thing that is
called the speed of light and until now
we weren't we weren't able to do
anything that is faster than that so and
this is around about 300 million meters
per second but in reality data and fiber
cable travels travels in more like 200
million a million meters per second this
means for one data package to go to New
York and coming back to Hamburg it
already takes 62 milliseconds and this
is for only one single data package and
I would not like to to have a look on
what happens on the network when we are
requesting a website or when we are
connecting to a server so what do we
have to do and how many round trips this
this causes so the first thing we have
to do is we have to kind of find out
where we can or how we can connect to
the server and in order to do so we need
to ask domain name server for its IP
address so in this case I will just
answer again ask the DNS server hey DNS
server I would like to go to some domain
in this case it's def has two E and then
the DNS server will resolve that for me
and give me the I
Piedras back and this already has taken
60 62 milliseconds and then because HTTP
uses TCP as its transportation layer we
also have to open a TCP connection so
and in order to do that we send a
package and then we get as soon
synchronization and acknowledgement
package back which also adds another two
round-trips to open the connection where
we are now already at 120 124
milliseconds but now we are in the year
2018 and most websites are delivered
securely which means we also have to do
a TLS or SSL handshake which in itself
adds another two round-trips because we
have to kind of exchange information
about which cipher suits are supported
and then we need to exchange the keys
and also the certificate and then in the
end we can send the encrypted messages
and like I said this already this also
adds another two round-trips and now we
already eight 248 in milliseconds and
the best case conditions right so we
didn't even account for the DNS server
having to calculate the response or any
routers that take up some time and this
is a quarter of a second already and we
also neglected one major thing that most
or a lot of current network traffic goes
over mobile networks which by their
sheer nature are always add in a fixed
amount of latency to to each data that
is to each package that is going to be
sent so for example for a te this as
well as small it's only 70 milliseconds
but if you are on on 3G which is pretty
common and in most countries this is
already on already between 150
milliseconds or 400 milliseconds and on
2g you are basically lost because it's
almost one second for each request and
if you if you do the math then you can
add up for normal 3G connection to like
to open a connection to to a web server
it's already 1,000 milliseconds so one
second before any data is sent at all
and when I research this I was kind of
impression that cannot be cannot be true
because just seems way to match
but then I wanna run a test on a service
that is called webpagetest.org so if you
don't know it yet then please look it up
it's super awesome if you want to just
see how your website is performing it
has a lot of more features than only
this waterfall chart but this is the
waterfall chart in this case I requested
usa.gov
from a server in Frankfurt I think under
3G conditions and I covered the download
part so with this icon so what you could
see there is only what it takes to
connect to the website so it's DNS TCP
and TLS and it's already 1.4 or 1.3
seconds so it's actually it's actually
true so now that we opened the
connection we can happily start sending
data in full-speed right well of course
not doesn't work because TCP has a bunch
of algorithms in place that protect the
network from collapsing because you
cannot just send data if your recipient
does not be it's not able to handle the
data and then you would just congest the
entire network and it will break down so
and one-one-one algorithm is called tcp
slow-start and it works in the way that
when you start sending data it only does
it slowly so you have to send one
package and then you have to wait to get
one back before you can send even more
data and this slowly increases until you
at some point reach maximum maximum
speed and usually this amount of data is
14 kilobytes so if you happen to manage
to get your entire website into those 14
kilobytes then you have only one
additional one trip which would be
awesome but I don't know if anybody is
capable of doing that nowadays so yeah
and the thing is that when you're using
HTTP one and not HTTP two then you have
this tcp slow-start punishment so to
speak for each connection that you are
having so if you are downloading images
five images from the same host then
you're opening five connections and you
have to endure' tcp slow-start for each
of those connections and this leads to
to the following conclusion that usually
latency and not bandwidth causes slow
because in this example it didn't matter
much if I have 100 M it's 100 connection
or 50 m 8 or 10 or 1 gigabit because we
didn't send large data yet and engineers
over the years came up with a lot of
techniques to mitigate those issues and
to decrease latency so first of all
there is now HTTP to multiplexing which
allows you to reuse open TCP connections
so when you are downloading 5 images
from the same house then only one
connection will be used so you can
probably download the third fourth and
fifth image on our full speed and you
don't and you are not subject to TCP
slows at five times but only once then
there is content delivery networks which
basically try to move their servers
closer to the users location and
literally decreasing the distance data
has to travel and therefore reducing
latency and the third one is caching and
with caching you can kind of remove
bring the related sea down to almost
zero because once the file is in the
cache it will be just delivered from
either the disk or the memory the issue
was with with that is that it only works
for the second request because in order
to be able to serve it from the cache
you somehow need to to put it there and
that usually happens only when you when
you see it when you download it so and
this is where resource hints come into
play so resource ins a kind of a way of
predictive caching it gives you the
ability to point the browser to
resources such as scripts CSS files
documents images whatever you can think
about before the browser can even know
that it's going to need them either for
this same request or for a request that
might be the next one or even two
requests away and the best or one cool
thing about it that implementation is
also water is simple because usually you
can just inject a link tag into your
head and get going and I would now like
to go through all of them basically and
show what they can do for you and how
you can use the
some example so you can use them and I
would like to start with preconnect
because preconnect does all the things
that I just mentioned it resolves the
DNS it performs the TCP handshake and
also does the TLS setup and I would like
to give one concrete example for that
and this is web fun so who has weapons
on their website or worked on a website
that's most so I also created a website
I have this catch-up and I have an issue
I have an issue so I need this platform
because the website needs to be cute so
I can give most the kid the kid is a new
home but I also needed to be loading
fast because otherwise my conversion
will drop and I don't want that so this
is how my my hat looks like currently
and I have half the stylesheet
my personal style sheet but I also have
the Google web font style sheet and
maybe most of you already know but I'm
going to mention any way Google is
offering a rather popular web service
where you can download reference from
which is called Google web fonts and
here's the the web font style sheet so
my style sheet is rather simple it only
contains the font family in the flow
which is the web form that I'm going to
download and of course also the color
Fox here because CIA and branding and
this is the Google web font style sheet
and it's and it's important to know that
this is not the web font file itself
it's only the style sheet that
references that references the actual
web font and you can see here it's for
the name in the flow and then there's
the URL that points to to the web font
file I will come to that in a second
when I now open my web site this is how
the waterfall chart looks like and can
you even see that okay awesome and so at
first my website is downloaded so we I
added some annotations so first DNS and
then TCP TLS and then you see the actual
requests happening and once my web site
is downloaded the browser sees that I
have embedded my my stylesheet and also
the Google web fonts
and then it will download both both of
them in parallel and as you can see here
like at the bottom only after both have
been downloaded it will download the bed
front itself and why is that the case
so browsers usually tend to download as
little data as possible to not waste any
bandwidth so they are only downloading
for example background images or web
fonts when they are actually used on the
page and in order to know if they are
used in the page they have to download
all the style sheets and then also and
also the HTML and then apply the style
sheets and check the selectors and see
if those selectors match and then
download the images and reference or or
not and this is why they have to
download both of them only then will
download the actual headphones and as
you can all my might be able to see it
takes roughly 4.2 seconds to download
the entire page under 3G conditions so
there's one important thing about the
Google web font API that is that the
path is not stable so if you would if
you were just to preload the entire font
then it wouldn't work because it might
change to more or in a week you cannot
know but what is relatively low but has
been relatively stable throughout the
years is that it is going to be served
from a host that is called fond stodgy
steady calm so that hasn't changed in
years or I don't know if it hasn't
changed at all ever so what you can do
is you can add a link tag to your head
with the rel set to pre connect so and
the atrial set to where the funds are
going to be downloaded from and this
will advise the browser to Otel force
the browser basically to already connect
against this host so doing DNS TCP
handshake and he'll essentially and then
there's also across originator boots
which we ignore for now and I will come
to this in a second as well because it's
kinda interesting but if we if we add
this to our hat then the resulting
waterfall suddenly looks like this so
again my website is downloaded and then
it starts it downloads the both style
sheets parallel as before but now it
already
connects to to the host of the of the
web font it doesn't download it yet so
you might
notice the gap because it still needs to
evaluate both CSS files in order to know
if it's actually going to be needed but
we already told the browser that we want
to connect against this house which it
does right away so that when the
wavefront file needs to be downloaded it
will be much much faster because you
don't have to open the connection
because it's already been opened and now
it's only three seconds or 3.1 seconds
so we got rid of more than a second of
Patriot time by only adding this link
tag to the head I think is kinda mazing
quickly going back to this cross origin
attribute so for I guess for DRM reasons
funds Bev funds are subject to to the
same origin policy so that you cannot
just include reference from from anybody
and the front face specification
requires that funds are loaded in an
enemy's cause mode and for some reason I
don't know maybe some of you can answer
this is browsers appear to maintain a
separate pool of TCP connections for
those kind of requests which means if
you do not set cross origin then you
will have two TCP connections because it
cannot reuse the first one so let's have
a look at the browser support so the
browser support is actually pretty good
it's only it's supported for is for 70%
of users apparently already so I think
it's safe to - already just use it the
second one is the second resource hint
is called DNS prefetch and it's it is
kind of similar to how preconnect works
but it only does the DNS resolving and
does not open the TCP connection and
this is mostly useful for resources that
you will not need now but now wish where
you don't don't know if it's going to
happen in a second or maybe in five
seconds or maybe even in a minute and
one example I would like to give is
Amazon so Amazon has this autocomplete
feature which you might have already
seen and this was really quick but and
the thing is the autocomplete service
itself does not
live on amazon.com it actually lives on
completion amazon.com which is a
different host then amazon.com so if you
where to start typing your browser would
need to resolve this host before it can
actually make the request and what they
are doing is in their head they add this
rate link tag with the relation said to
DNS prefetch and the href said to
completion amazon.com so as soon as you
open their main page that's this is
already going to be resolved and when
you start typing it will will just
appear in work which is cool and also
simple and it has even better browser
support then then pre Connect which is
kind of interesting so what you can do
is if you actually want preconnect but
also want to give browsers that do not
support reconnect but to support DNS
prefetch at least something the DNS
prefetch you can basically just specify
both in one link tag and then if the
browser supports pre connect it will
simply use pre connect and if it does
not but our support DNS prefetch then it
will resort to DNS prefetch the next one
is prefetch and prefetch allows you to
to actually download resources but that
you that you don't need right now but
that you are going to need later and
like for future for future navigations
so and cache would supply so if you if
you download if you prefetch a file and
it has a cache lifetime of one hour then
if you come back later then it will
still be served from the cache the the
thing to know is that prefetch files
will not get it will not be executed so
it's totally safe to prefetch for
example scripts limiters they would just
be downloaded and with a low priority
and nothing will be done with it until
you two need it and it would like to
give to two examples for that as well
so going back to my cat store maybe so
usually an online store flow is is
pretty clear so I have a product page
and then I put products into my cart and
then I go to the cart page and then from
the cart page I go to the checkout which
sometimes is a separate check out a
separate
application and then I will do I will
give you my money there basically so
what you can do when I'm on the cart
page you can be pretty certain that I'm
going to go to the checkout as well
because if I'm already in the card why
wouldn't I
so you can at this point already
prefetch the the files that your app is
going to need for for the checkout
experience and then just prefetch them
and as soon as I hit this go to or
proceed to checkout button the stuff
will already be there and leading to
better experience the second example is
similar but maybe a bit different so if
you have a login page lock in a login
form then it's also you can also be
pretty certain that my intent is is to
log in and use the locked-in experience
so why not just real Oh a prefetch the
the assets images in scripts that you
need for the locked experience at this
point already because it doesn't hurt if
you are pretty sure that that I will
need them then you can use the bandwidth
and just give me a better better
experience and the browser support also
is pretty good it got all of this got a
lot better in recent months because in
this case not but also safari naira
safari started supporting we saw since
apart from this one apparently so this
is pretty good and this is even
supported in IE in edge so pretty safe
to use the last one I would like to talk
about is also the newest one and maybe
even the most interesting one it is
called preload and you can use preload
to download resources that you need for
the current navigation for the current
page view but that the browser cannot
know about yet but you do know so now I
would like to go back to my my to a bad
font example and just briefly go go back
to the initial initial waterfall chart
like the first one like just to recap
that we had to download both CSS files
and only afterwards the webform was
downloaded and I know I only said that
when we are using Google Wave phones we
cannot know the path but let's just
pretend for this example that we can
know the path and if you actually wanted
to use this technique you could also
consider
hosting the web font yourself and be in
control of the UL and then no no wait
for sure and all right we got one too
fast and sorry so and so what you can do
is add at this link tech we've preload
and then set it to the edge proof that
we know pretend that we know and what
happens then is if you look at the
resulting waterfall chart that the web
phone itself will be downloaded and
parallel with all the other stuff and
will be will be ready much much earlier
which was kind of cool you can use it
for for all kinds of stuff and we will
come to to that right now because if you
might have noticed there was this s
attribute in here and the S attribute is
the B crest type and you can have plenty
of them you can use scripts for example
if you have third-party scripts that you
are loading by an inline script loader
or you can have images that maybe are
referenced as background images in your
CSS files and you can even preload fetch
requests which bring which gives us
interesting interesting new stuff which
I don't want to get into detail right
now but why do we even have to set
request type why do we need it so it's
needed so that the browser can
prioritize the request because style
sheets might might be downloaded with a
higher priority than images but it is
also used to set the appropriate except
header so that the browser sense doesn't
request an image when you actually want
one a script from you or from your web
server so that you can deliver the right
thing but it's also used to enforce the
content security policy and if you were
in the first talk this morning you might
already know what it is about but
content security basically allows you in
this case to specify from which host you
want to allow to download resources from
for example you could say I only want to
allow images to be downloaded from image
server com
whereas scripts should be downloaded
from script server calm and in order to
enforce that Google will air Google the
browser needs to know with what kind of
file type it is dealing with and if you
fail
to set a resource type or set incorrect
one then you will have basically have
double fetches and preload will not give
you anything
one other thing is there's responsive
design so if you which is basically
trying to make your your web app work
across screen sizes right and oftentimes
you need to download resources depending
on the screen size for example the
background image for for mobile app for
mobile version might be a completely
different one than the one for the
desktop experience and usually people
use media queries for that so you
specify a max width and then if the max
width of your device is in the is in
this realm then it will download this
and otherwise the other luckily browser
vendors have this also in mind when they
invented preload so you can use the
media actually boot and in preload in
the link tag as well and then said max
for example the max width and then the
browser will only download a preload
those where the media query actually
matches and here is the one the one
resource in where support got
significantly better in the last three
months even I think so it's now
supported in all major browsers but IE
and it's even already in at 17
apparently so I think it's now ready
ready to be used and I would definitely
look into that so and with that I'm
almost almost finished but I would like
to finish in this talk with two book
recommendations so if you're interested
in in this topic I can highly advise the
book high performance browser networking
by egoic this one is even available for
free as a progressive web app on the
internet so if we do google it and and
read it maybe on your way home and then
there's also an in fact basically the
first five to ten minutes in this talk
we're out of this book and then there's
also HTTP the definite guide which are
also enjoyed reading couple of years ago
so and with that I'd like to thank you
for listening and see you around
thank you
[Applause]